ils et elles sont 800 danseurs et
danseuses venues de 40 villes de france
pour ce qui est présenté comme une
compétition le championnat de france de
hip hop hip hop voici une culture de 40
hors d'âge partie déjà depuis belle
lurette les seuls banlieue en pop c'est
pas que de la danse est vraiment plein
de choses c'est ça aussi bien la musique
la façon de parler la façon de
s'habiller la façon de penser la façon
de vivre la façon de s'entraider
tout ça c'est hip hop championnat
championnat certes mais surtout
l'occasion de faire la fête car le
spectacle est déjà hors scène dans la
salle avant même que le show commence
[Applaudissements]
mais la fête malgré tout doit se plier
le cadre de la compétition avec des
jurys à la clé
[Applaudissements]
on a huit jury quatre ans performance
quatre ans technique un peu comme le
patinage artistique
donc chaque juge mes notes la note la
plus haute et la plus basse sont retirés
on garde la moyenne des deux ça se joue
donc au centième près ms en critères
techniques ça va être l'exécution des
styles de danse il faut un minimum de
trois styles de danse hip hop bien
exécuté ça peut être aussi la stabilité
au niveau des acrobaties ça ça va être
le côté technique et le côté artistique
bas on va retrouver plus la thématique
du show comment le public aussi a dit à
adhérer à la performance la créativité
perçu dans la performance premiers juges
et les ados catégorie junior de tout
jeunes adolescents une rigueur
implacable
ça demande énormément de d'énergie
énormément la gestion du stress une
rigueur dans le travail parce qu'ils
sont quand même neuf dans leur groupe
ils vont tous quand même des études
[Musique]
orient ce week-end aurait une fois
encore la capitale française cette
culture populaire au meilleur sens du
terme
né dans la rue pour le plaisir et pour
le sport
[Musique]